Wade Wilson returns in Deadpool 2 for
some wicked jabs at Wolverine Marvel and
much more in a sequel that's chock-full
of Easter eggs jokes and meta moments
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm breaking down the very
best Easter eggs and references you
might have missed in Deadpool 2 if
you're finding me for the first time do
subscribe to get all my new Deadpool and
Marvel videos plus I'm giving away some
awesome Deadpool 2 merch more details
later
obviously spoilers ahead for the movie
so take care if you haven't seen it yet
although dominoes survives thanks to her
power of good luck it's a bit of a
shocking moment when Deadpool's new
x-force team barely last a few minutes
before getting dispatched in various
gruesome ways but the x-force had
already faced this kind of bloodbath in
the comics where an x-force 116 almost
all the members of a new x-force team
were killed off in what was known as the
boys R Us Massacre part of the movies
x-force team was the Vanisher played by
Brad Pitt who we only actually see in
the film when his characters
electrocuted on power lines during a
parachute jump in the comics the vanish
is a teleporting criminal though at one
point he was forced to join the x-force
team when Deadpool gets covered in ash
during the final fight turning his red
suit gray it's a nod to his gray colored
x-force suit
therefore to reintroduces juggernaut
into the x-men movie world with the
villain having previously appeared in
x-men The Last Stand
after which some of his lines were
parodied becoming internet memes given
the x-men 3 was retconned away after
Days of Future Passed created a new
timeline this is presumably a new and
better juggernaut than Vinnie Jones's
version and this time juggernaut is all
CGI and his voice is provided by Ryan
Reynolds himself in the movie Deadpool
is a huge fan of juggernaut and when he
meets him he rattles off some of his
favorite comic book issues featuring the
unstoppable being there's uncanny x-men
183 where juggernaut aka Cain Marko
starts a bar brawl with Colossus then
the Thor 411 where juggernaut is taken
to New York by Loki and ends up in a
fight with the god of thunder
and there's x-men unlimited 12 where
Cain Marko was trapped inside the
Crimson gem of site Iraq and although
juggernaut appears to be defeated at the
end of the film having been electrocuted
then shoved into a pool if he
watch the final scene very carefully
you'll notice juggernaut is still alive
moving around in the pool so it seems he
shares his comic-book counterparts power
of near invulnerability in Deadpool -
juggernaut also reveals that he wears a
helmet because his brother who's in a
wheelchair tries to read his mind this
is a reference to juggernauts family
history and the comics where he's
actually the stepbrother of Professor X
who of course uses a wheelchair
Wade actually spends some time wheeling
around in that famous wheelchair at the
x-mansion and there's a funny moment
with Wade ranting about the studio not
giving Deadpool any top-tier x-men for
his movie what Wade doesn't realize
though is that just behind him there's a
roomful of x-men including Quicksilver
Cyclops Nightcrawler Professor X and
beast who quietly closes a door on the
Marvel motormouth during his x-men rant
Deadpool mentions the one with giant
pigeon wings likely a reference to angel
who worked for apocalypse in the
previous x-men movie later on there's
also an amusing scene of Wade wearing
cerebro and pretending to know what
Colossus is thinking
Deadpool jokes that it smells like
Patrick Stewart and also breaks cerebro
as he takes us off death Falls rivalry
with Wolverine and Hugh Jackman
continues in the sequel the film begins
with a musical figure of an impaled
Wolverine in a throwback to how he died
at the end of Logan Wade also complains
about Logan copying Deadpool's r-rating
and the musical theme don't be what they
made you from the Logan's soundtrack
which played when Logan died also plays
in Deadpool - as Deadpool tries to talk
fire fist down from killing the
headmaster and when Deadpool signs a
packet of cornflakes for a young kid
that has Hugh Jackman's Wolverine on the
packet it could be a nod to Laura
aka x-23 in the Logan movie by the way
the child actor who plays the kid with a
cereal box in Deadpool - also appears in
the TV show Legion as a young mutant
David Haller
whose father in the comics is Professor
X there's also another Hugh Jackman nod
via Deadpool's hand-drawn plan which
features a picture of Wolverine in the
DMC prison with the number two for 601
above it that was the same prisoner
number that Jackman's character Jean
Valjean had in lame is Rob Lowe deathful
- doesn't really tackle cables mutant
origins but there is a nice
easter-egg to his mother Madeline prior
by the priors treats ice cream van which
pops up near the Billboard where
Deadpool lands with his parachute
Madeline Pryor was a clone of Jean Grey
and was created by mr. sinister with the
aim of her having a child with Scott
Summers aka Cyclops so that mr. sinister
could use their offspring as a weapon
deadpool also makes a joke about cables
height in the movie and how he's only 5
foot 11 much shorter than in the comics
where his height is typically around 6
foot 8 sheriff Deadpool you know you're
a lot taller and shut up you little and
when cable tells Deadpool you're not a
hero you're just an annoying clown
dressed up as a sex toy it's a hat tip
to Deadpool's hatred of clowns in the
comics which was also referenced in the
first movie during his visit to the
oncologist another mister sinister
connection comes by the essex school for
the young the institution where both
fire fist and Domino were raised mister
Sinister's real name is Nathaniel Essex
and the supervillain was last teased in
the x-men apocalypse post-credit scene
where men working for Essex Corp entered
the Weapon X facility to collect vials
of mutant blood which likely also
contains samples of Wolverines blood it
will be interesting to see where the mr.
sinister is slowly being set up as a big
bad for the whole of Fox's x-men
franchise and the Essex school with its
cult-like propaganda and anti-mutant
agenda feels reminiscent of the
purifiers in the comics the purifiers
were set up by the fanatical x-men hater
William Stryker and became a
quasi-religious organization that
carried out terrorist attacks on the
mutant population among the propaganda
at the school are banners which say n
day is here M day which is also known as
the decimation is the Marvel Comics
event in which Scarlet Witch D powered
masses of mutants and Auntie mutant
leaders like William Stryker saw em day
as a kind of divine signal to take
further steps against the remaining
mutant population devil 2 also features
tons of callbacks to moments from the
first deadpool movie but one especially
interesting one is how the sequel pays
off a line that wade said to blind al in
the 2016 film
it's about 116 kilos of cocaine buried
somewhere in the apartment right next to
the cure for blindness good luck and
just as he promised we see a package
labeled cure for blindness nestled among
Wade's stash of coke in dead
- by the way according to an AW
interview with Deadpool back in 2016
codswallop the last thing that Deadpool
says in the sequel just before he dies
is his favorite word
not only does Deadpool use the
post-credits scenes to go back and fix
the timeline by shooting himself in
x-men origins Wolverine but he also
pokes fun at another crazy scene in that
movie in Deadpool - during his fight
with cable on board the convoy Deadpool
rapidly moves his katanas in an almost
futile attempt to block the bullets from
cables guns though he does manage to
split one bullet into has also happened
in origins Wolverine of course here Wade
ends up full of bullet holes unlike his
alter-ego in origins with a Merc with a
mouth miraculously deflected a hail of
incoming bullets as Team X entered the
HQ of a diamond smuggling operation also
in the post credits Deadpool calls
negasonic teenage warhead xi referencing
elf from stranger things whose
extraordinary psychokinetic abilities
have been likened to Jean Grey with
stranger things itself having made
numerous x-men references on the show
after he's fitted with a Power
suppressing collar at the mutant prison
Deadpool pokes fun at the
non-superpowered archer clint barton
saying give me a bow and arrow and I'm
basically hawkeye Deadpool also tries to
calm down the enormous juggernaut using
the same words that Black Widow used to
talk the Hulk back down to being Bruce
Banner in the MCU hey big guy Suns
getting real low
however Deadpool's not the first to make
fun of that line from age of ultron
director Taika Waititi got there first
in Thor Ragnarok Josh Brolin who plays
cable also placed a nose in the MCU and
the mad Titan gets a shout out when
Deadpool tells cable zip hit Thanos
Deadpool also calls cable an old grump
of the Winter Soldier armed comparing
him to the Marvel character Bucky who
also has a cybernetic limb and when the
motormouth smirk finds out that cables
from the future he asked the time
traveler at what point to audiences say
enough with the robotic arms just before
his Basic Instinct parody Deadpool also
calls Domino black Black Widow and
towards the end of the movie he caused a
Pinder brown panther whether he's
selling hotdogs on a beach listening to
music in a library or delivering
packages to Tony
stun these cameos have become a
highlight of many Marvel movies in the
first Deadpool film li popped up as a DJ
at a strip club at the time Li said that
was his favorite cameo however you won't
see Stan the man in person in Deadpool 2
instead this time his cameo is more akin
to his appearances and Netflix's various
Marvel shows so look out for a big mural
of Lee as Domino parachutes into the
city to intercept the convoy
transporting fire fist also according to
the screenwriters the statue that
Deadpool knocks over in the x-mansion is
actually a bust of Stan Lee as well
captain Marvel's getting her debut solo
movie in the MCU next year and Deadpool
2 includes a sneaky nod to the alpha
flight superhero team which Carol
Danvers recently led in Marvel Comics
the alpha flight Easter Egg appears on
the top of depend astac see as an ad for
a Canadian airline offering cheap
flights and travel deals before Captain
Marvel recently headed up the team alpha
flight was a Canadian superhero team
introduced in uncanny x-men number 120
and has had numerous members over the
years including Wolverine Guardian
Northstar Aurora and Snowbird their
fallen spider-man half history in the
comics and the Merc with the mouth
sometimes even gets confused with the
wall crawler due to similarities in
their outfits so it's not surprising to
find some Spidey nods in Deadpool 2
first up there's what looks like a
spider symbol on one of the kitchen
cabinets near the entrance to wade in
Vanessa's apartment and just before
Colossus goes up against juggernaut
Deadpool says go get em tiger kirsten
dunst 'as MJ said those same words to
Tobey Maguire's Peter at the very end of
spider-man 2 and face it tiger you just
hit the jackpot
where mary jane's first words to Peter
Parker in the comics by the way Kirsten
Dunst also gets name-checked for her
role in the film interview with the
vampire which gets discussed by defender
and Deadpool towards the start of the
movie after we've watched Deadpool blast
himself to smithereens and a montage of
his numerous kills the Merc with a mouth
tells us that Deadpool 2 is actually a
family film and just like all good
family films it starts with a vicious
murder to prove his point
Deadpool name-checks two animated Disney
classics Bambi and The Lion King both of
which feature earlier
total deaths and to hammer home the joke
Wade also includes saw seven on his list
of family films as well
you'll hear the song tomorrow from the
musical Annie several times during
Deadpool to this particular version is
from a 1999 Disney TV special as the
famous musical about a young orphan the
song fits with Deadpool twos idea that
kids give us a chance to be better than
we used to be as Vanessa says and given
that the song is all about optimism it
seems especially fitting that it plays
during scenes with cable and his
daughter whose name is hope and tomorrow
also plays during the scene where
Deadpool sacrifices himself to save five
fists interestingly there are also a
couple of viral videos out there of Ryan
Reynolds performing his own version of
tomorrow one on a Korean TV show and
another in a birthday message with Hugh
Jackman despite Vanessa's reassurances
Wade worries that when they have
children he'll be a bad father like his
own dad Annie even cites Star Wars as
evidence that men are destined to become
their father then have consensual sex
with their sister obviously Wade's
thinking of Luke and Darth Vader's
relationship and of Luke kissing layer
which Vanessa reminds him was actually
in the Empire Strikes Back
when Deadpool shows his hand-drawn plan
to his ex force crew you can see the
words pew-pew scrawled in crayon next
two cables gun which is a hat tip to the
noise made by blasters in the Star Wars
movies another Star Wars nod comes in
the credits where the actress who plays
Yukio gets a note pointing out that the
ex force is strong with this one perhaps
suggesting that Yukio will be returning
in the x-force movie there's a running
joke about Disney Animation's
highest-grossing movie frozen during
Deadpool - it starts off when Wade and
Vanessa watching Barbara Streisand sing
cover can you hear me in the movie Yentl
and Wade asks does this song sound
familiar to you
and it continues at weasels bar with
Deadpool asking is it just me or just do
you want to build a snowman from frozen
sounds suspiciously like Papa can you
hear me from Yentl Deadpool seems kind
of annoyed about it but depended just
loves frozen alan tudyk who voices a
Duke of weselton in the animated movie
makes a brief appearance in Deadpool 2
as redneck number one whose conversation
about toilet paper with another redneck
character played by an unrecognizable
Matt Damon is cut short when cable
arrived
takes their truck a scene which has
vibes of Terminator 2 where Arnold
Schwarzenegger also robbed a vehicle
from some rednecks by the way in real
life Barbra Streisand who co-wrote
directed and starred in Yentl is a
stepmother of Josh Brolin Deadpool two's
cable Rob Liefeld who co-created the
comic-book character Deadpool got
several name checks in the first
Deadpool movie and Deadpool 2 continues
a shout outs for example when Wayde
stops complaining about which comic book
artists came up with a character whose
superpowers look he ran said it was
probably someone who can't draw feet
which is a wink at live fells
interesting perspective on Anatomy
especially feet in his comic book
drawings and when cable turns up at
blind Al's apartment his utility belt
draws some sarcastic remarks from weasel
which is a reference to life elves
trademark pouch laid in comic book
costumes at the start of the film
Deadpool very deliberately blows
cigarette smoke towards the camera which
could be a little dick at Disney who
found character smoking in any pg-13
films including Marvel Star Wars and
Pixar my question to you guys now is
which were your favorite Easter eggs or
moments in Deadpool 2 be sure to comment
and subscribe for a chance to win this
awesome Deadpool merch and if you
enjoyed this do like and share the video
and remember to turn on your
notifications the winner of my last
giveaway is on screen now so if that's
you make sure you private message me
with your details you can check out more
of my Deadpool 2 and Marvel videos by
tapping the screen here thanks for
watching and see you next time you
became movie lovers